5 55 on your friday morning what's
driving you crazy how about when a
completion date may not exactly be a
completion date where us 95 meets the
northern 215 beltway come on
let's go
centennial bowling all right we have
mentioned many times in the past that
the nevada department of transportation
is on track to
finish up the last of those freeway to
freeway flyover
ramps in the centennial bowl before the
end of the year of course we're talking
about the one that'll take
southbound u.s 95 drivers to the
eastbound 215.
well technically that still may be the
case but ndot's tony ilya tells us that
upon
further review if they were to allow
traffic
on that ramp well they would only end up
taking taking it away less than a month
later
because of the next and final phase of
that project so here's that deal
beginning in january crews are going to
start on 155 million dollars worth of
all kinds of work in around over and
under those fancy flyovers
so the bottom line is that last flyover
is not going to open
until all of that work is done and that
may not be until
july of 2021 so that map that i keep
showing
it really might be worth your time
checking out because there is a lot to
take in so all you
traffic nerds head on over to our
website 8newsnow.com click traffic and
then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put on that phone
now if there is something driving you
crazy email me with pictures and video
to traffic 8
8newsnow.com